hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde einige von euch haben sich
bereits gefragt warum meine reaction auf
das neue lied von katja nicht mehr
verfügbar das liegt ganz einfach daran
dass ich gestern im livestream auf
meinem zweikanal luke ruhm mir zusammen
mit euch nochmal die resonanz unter
meiner action angeschaut habe und dabei
ist mir aufgefallen dass einige
kommentarschreiber meinte hey luca
normalerweise freien wir deinen
reactions aber hier jetzt von einigen
stellen weniger lustig locker sein
sollen sondern wirklich dem thema die
ernsthaftigkeit wirklich entgegen
bringen sollen die es verdient hat
daraufhin habe ich mir live im stream
nochmal meine eigene reaction auf das
lied von katja angeschaut habe selber
auch festgestellt haye an 34 stellen
hätte ich einfach ernster bleiben müssen
beispielsweise an einer stelle habe ich
so etwas gemacht beispielsweise aha so
zu einem lied was da wirklich eigentlich
nicht richtig zu passt da muss ich mich
ganz klar entschuldigen und zwar habe
ich mich wirklich vor deren reaction
nicht über das video oder die
hintergründe des liedes informiert das
ist der sinn einer reaktion finde ich
dass man halt einfach unvoreingenommen
da reingeht allerdings wusste ich nicht
das hat ja mit diesem lied ihre
tragische kindheit und bisschen
verarbeiten möchte und deswegen waren
einige szenen von mir wo ich halt
einfach lustig locker darauf reagiert
habe wirklich unangebracht ich will
allerdings auf der anderen seite jetzt
keine riesen fass aufmachen wo keins ist
gestern im live-chat haben sich einige
beschwert dass ich mich die ganze zeit
rechtfertigen soll und das ist einfach
nur langweilig sei dass ich da weiter zu
argumentieren weiter und so fort sondern
ich wollte einfach nur hier kurz
stellung beziehen ich habe mich scheiße
gefühlt wenn meine reaktion so weiter
online gewesen wäre habt ihr eine
nachricht auf instagram geschrieben ich
glaube es ist alles cool aber nur für
euch da ganz kurz die info warum meine
reaktion nicht mehr online ist
allerdings habe ich mir dann gedacht und
ich glaube das passt zum thema gerade
ganz gut dass wir uns heute einfach mal
von der biograf bevor katja krawitz
berühmt wurde anschauen katja krasavac
kam am 10 august 1996 als kat
die jünger als ich das hätte ich nicht
gedacht mit mutter vater und den beiden
deutlich älteren brüdern zog sie mit
vier jahren nach deutschland und landete
im sächsischen dorf liebschütz
ich dachte die hat ihr leben lang schon
immer in berlin gewohnt erscheint war
ich komplett falsch informiert über ihr
leben vom fernseher vertrieb sie sich
als zehnjährige die zeit gerne damit
musikvideos ihrer lieblings stars
anzusehen wie sie sich kleideten und
tanzten prägte katja schönheitsideal
so wusste sie wohl schon in der
grundschule dass sie sich später einmal
die brüste vergrößern lassen möchte
in der grundschule schon okay krass auch
hier möchte ich ganz kurz sagen keine
kommentare von mir wie beispielsweise
jetzt ok krass oder so sollen verletzend
gemeint sein ich will jetzt nicht in so
eine spirale reinrutschen dass ich mich
die ganze zeit für alles rechtfertige so
ihr wisst ich will keinen menschen was
böses um die mir sowas zu herzen seit
der ganzen klub sache und versuch es
allen leuten die mehr oder weniger
rechts machen aber bitte versteht keine
kommentare sind irgendwie negativ
gemeint auch was das auftreten
anbelangte eiferte sie ihren vorbildern
nach zur schoss sie in ihrem
kinderzimmer oft fotos von sich knapp
bekleidet in verführerischen posen
das ist aber jetzt gerade bisschen
überspitzt aber ist nicht dass sie nach
grundschüler schon so playboy kissen und
so hat er nur kam ihrer outfits dort
nicht wirklich gut an
ihre klassenkameraden tuschelten hinter
vorgehaltener hand keiner wollte mit ihr
sprechen oder spiel
ich glaube
denk hat ja jetzt im jahr 2020 so in die
grundschule gehen würde wie sie es dann
anscheinend vor 15 jahren gemacht hat
haben wir erst ganz anders gelaufen
wir können uns echt glücklich schätzen
was wir jetzt gerade in einer zeit leben
wo du dich wirklich kleiden kannst wie
du möchtest das war wirklich damals
unfassbar da musst du nur löcher in
einer hose haben und wurde gemobbt quasi
doch trotzdem konnten die vogels wie die
familie in deutschland hieß gemeinsam
viel lachen eine von katjas liebsten
erinnerung ist dass einer ihrer brüder
songtexte extra falsch lang um sie damit
zu belustigen
als katja zwölf jahre alt war zog sie
mit ihrer mutter ins 60 kilometer
entfernte leipzig in der sächsischen
messestadt kam sie auf eine neue schule
und wie das nun mal so ist im
teenager-alter verliebte sie sich zum
ersten mal dass sie von diesem jungen
zurückgewiesen wurde ging vielleicht
damit zusammen dass katja auch auf der
neuen schule keinen anschluss fand ich
glaube dass es aber generell schwierig
ich weiß noch immer als bei uns
irgendwie neue mitglieder in die klasse
kamen das war sooo schwer die einerseits
zu integrieren aber die hat noch immer
probleme damit irgendwie aus sich
herauszukommen
das ist von beiden seiten schwierig zum
mobbing vorfälle hatten wir nie zum
glück richtig an unserer schule das hat
unsere schule wirklich gut gemanagt aber
ich kann mir vorstellen dass wirklich
hart waren immer sie mit ihrem dicken
make up tiefen ausschnitt und kurzem
rock auf ihren high heels durch die
klassenräume stolzierte begann die
mitschüler zu lästern und zu spalten
also es halt schwierig na klar das ist
jetzt nicht so dass angebrachtes schule
outfit glaube ich aber jeder soll sich
anziehen dürfen wie er möchte
das habe ich ja meine reaction auch
schon gesagt so es ist einfach katja
style so ein kurzes knappes blaues kleid
klar ich glaube bei einem song richtig
ernsten lied hätte ich persönlich ein
anderes eine andere outfit wahl gewählt
weil gewählt bitte aber jeder soll sich
anziehen dürfen und das machen dürfen
worauf er bock hat aber wenn dich halt
andere leute dafür dann mobben oder
sondern sind das halt einfach fett
anders kann man es nicht beschreiben
zunächst wollte niemand mit ihr abhängen
weil sie als uncool galt dann wurde sie
angesteckt
angespuckt ja auch an jenem tag an dem
sie schon morgens ein mulmiges gefühl
verspürt stieg sie nach schulschluss aus
dem bus und erwartete dort eigentlich
ihre mutter an der haltestelle standen
jetzt allerdings zwei polizisten und
begleiteten sie nach hause
was war geschehen ach das war oh gott
ich bekomme direkt gänsehaut das war das
was mir dann auch im livestream chatten
die kommentare geschrieben wurde der
suizid ihres bruders war nicht der
einzige schicksalsschlag in katjas
jungem leben auch hier anderer bruder
starb
er verlor den kampf gegen den krebs wann
genau sich die beiden todesfälle
ereigneten
darüber spricht katja heute nicht
rückblickend gibt sie aber an dass sie
sich in ihrer kindheit und jugend
unfassbar allein gefühlt habe
denn zum verlust ihrer brüder und der
tatsache dass sie ohne freunde da stand
kam auch noch die trennung ihrer eltern
hinzu also
das inhalt
die ich form einer reaktion nicht so
richtig wusste
ihr bruder hat einfach suizid begangen
relativ zeitnah den kampf gegen krebs
verloren so ich wusste dass beide
gestorben waren da stand in den
kommentaren unter dem video aber das ist
ja noch mal eine ganz andere liga
ich will nicht wissen wie es ist wenn
man so im teenager alter
solche verluste mitmachen muss
so bei mir war es letztes jahr extrem
krasses in ganz kurzen zeitraum drei
meiner großeltern verstorben sind und
dann einfach so mit anzusehen wie meine
eltern halt so getrauert haben und so
das war das schlimmste und dass so etwas
will ich nie wieder haben in meinem
leben aber
das in so jungen jahren
seine brüder mit denen du jeden tag
verbringt
was du deine einzige stütze im leben ist
ich denke dass es nicht fair auf der
einen seite unterdrückte sie ihre
gefühle vollständig fraß die trauer um
ihre brüder komplett in sich hinein und
sprach mit niemandem über ihren koma auf
der anderen seite pochte sie auf angriff
statt sich für die die sie mobbten zu
verändern legte sie noch eine schippe
drauf das ist krass
also ich bin auch ein mensch dass sich
negative sachen er mich rein fressen als
das zeige so ich weiß noch als die haare
keine ahnung also es ist jeder geht
anders mit mit mit trauer und mit
schmerzen aber wenn man quasi die stärke
besitzt zu sagen ja ja da kann er mir
fallen keine worte dazu ein auch als
katja mit 16 jahren auf die idee kam ein
eigenes musikvideo zu drehen wurde sie
von ihrer mama supportet
das so süß wenn deine eltern egal was du
machst einfach hinter dir stehen um
ihrer tochter eine teure kamera kaufen
und die miete in einem tonstudio zu
bezahlen hey das ist unfassbar wenn
deine eltern so was für dich machen
also ich liebe meine eltern auch über
alles aber bei mir war es leider nicht
der fall so ich musste alles was ich
haben wollte musste ich drauf sparen und
blabla also das ist natürlich auch eine
art der erziehung so seitdem weiß ich
einfach alles zu schätzen und so weiter
und so fort aber es ist natürlich auch
hammer wenn deine eltern einfach sagen
ja mach ich support dich da ich nehme an
ihr schon weniges geld und steckt alles
in mein kind so
es schon nice ich wusste auch gar nicht
dass katja direkt zu beginn bevor sie
mit youtube angefangen hat erst direkt
sogar musik machen wollte doch mit dem
ersten video war es noch nicht so weit
so wusste sie schon bei der produktion
des clips da sie sich halbnackt zeigte
und ihrer stimme nicht sonderlich gut
war dass sie eine breite angriffsfläche
für hacker bieten würde
krass da gibt es dieses cover noch
irgendwo ab 2014 postete sie videos
unter ihrem alter ego katja kraus avicii
der falsche tschechische nach name
bedeutet übrigens schönheit auf deutsch
ach so ich dachte halt wirklich immer
dass sie einfach glaser vize mit
nachnamen heißt und ich hätte auch sogar
gesagt sie hat katja glaser witz
also jetzt hat ja krasa witschi
und eigentlich heißt die katja vogel
sind so sachen die wusste ich gar nicht
ich finde es so krass wenn man sogar
leute irgendwie wenn man von leuten ein
bild hat und dann irgendwie mehr über
die person erfährt und dann weiß woher
das bild kommt oder wie ihr wisst was
ich meine glaube ich oftmals schenken
hier heute sogar die hater aus
schulzeiten die anerkennung die er
damals fehlte wie es dabei hinter ihrer
fassade aus und darüber schweigt sie
weiterhin und versteckt den schmerz
hinter ihrem aufgespritzten lächeln
na ja also ich meine das video hier vom
biografen ist ein halbes jahr alt so ihr
song haben jetzt vor ein paar tagen raus
ich glaube das ist jetzt so ihre art und
weise damit so ein bisschen an die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen und damit
umzugehen bzw mit ihrem buch halt was
sie glaube ich raus gebracht hat oder
auch hörbuch ich weiß es nicht wie
gesagt haben beides nicht angeschaut bzw
angehört aber ich finde es immer extrem
krass ob ich gerade schon gesagt zu
einer person zu erfahren was die
hintergründe sind wie eine person die
person geworden ist die sie jetzt gerade
ist und was sich halt extrem krass finde
jetzt ja wer damals relativ häufig auf
catia videos und musik reagiert wo sie
sich halt freizügig gezeigt hat und nur
über sex und keine ahnung was gerappt
hat und wie viele leute sich schon hatte
und so weiter und so fort hin ich die
entwicklung hat auf der anderen seite
extrem krass das jetzt zu dieser ernsten
person geworden ist und ich hoffe katja
dass wir dabei bleibt zwar das gefällt
mir und ich glaube sehr vielen anderen
deutlich besser als die songs die die
davor gemacht hast dennoch bleib wie du
bist mach was du machen möchtest du dich
anders zu machen
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine meine
lieben freunde das heute war einfach nur
so ein kleiner exkurs ins leben von
katja glaser wird aus gegebenem anlass
weil ich ja gestern abend im leibchen
mit euch doch mal unter hat die
kommentare von meinem video geschaut
habe und mein video dementsprechend
offline genommen habe weil ich mich
dabei einfach nicht mehr wohl gefühlt
habe ich will kein größeres fass
aufmachen und jetzt irgendwie aus einer
mücke einen elefanten machen oder keine
ahnung was nennt es wie ihr wollt aber
ich glaube ist es besser so und ich
glaube es ist gut dass wir uns alle mal
die vergangenheit von katja glaser vize
bzw
katja vogels zu gemüte geführt haben von
daher meine lieben freunde wenn euch das
video gefallen hat das gern einen daumen
hoch da katja song findet ihr noch mal
unten verlinkt und was sich auch noch an
[Musik]